we're joined by a sted Herndon national
political reporter for the New York
Times the sted good morning let's start
with that with the pushback from the
special counsels office saying this that
the BuzzFeed report is not accurate does
that feel like a denial or what exactly
do you think it is I think we have to
take it seriously because of how rare
these statements are from the special
counsels office they are coming out
against the report but the wording was
interesting they did not say kind of
blanketly that it was a full hundred
percent denials the white house is
saying they said that some of the
descriptors that BuzzFeed use were not
accurate and so BuzzFeed has asked for
clarification and say come out and say
what the parts that of the report were
inaccurate we haven't seen that from the
special counsel's office I doubt we see
that from the special counsels office
but I think that it puts us in a
difficult position we know that they're
denying parts of it we don't know how
full that is we do know the White House
is denying it blanketly but we've seen
the White House previously deny things
that have come out to be true this
pushback is pretty extraordinary
but the pushback is notable is is
extraordinary because of just how rare
it is and what you say it's a difficult
position especially for members of the
house right now they've said we're
waiting on impeachment we want to see
this full report but you have this
report hanging there does that change
anything it will for some Democrats I
mean you said you had immediately after
BuzzFeed story some Democrats come out
on Twitter and in statements saying if
this is true we need to move with
impeachment immediately since we have
this pushback I expect that's a cool
little bit that if that if it's really
important but there's a number of House
Democrats especially on the more
progressive side who have been calling
for impeachment for a while now the
house leadership doesn't want that
they've been able to quell those calls
but for that community the impeachment
process there they're ready to get
started any day let's talk about the
government shutdown president says he's
gonna have a major announcement later on
this afternoon what do you expect him to
say now we know that he's likely not to
call for a national emergency which some
folks have been pushing him to do
especially those part of his
conservative base but we think it's
gonna happen is that he's gonna offer
Democrats a deal and maybe a better deal
than we've had previously the details of
that are kind of unknown but we know
that's gonna be a hard sell Democrats
have kind of said blanketly
that they're uninterested in wall
funding that this is something that was
a priority for the
right now but there's been kind of a
non-starter for them so any deal is
gonna be very difficult so what gets us
to a deal here it's hard to imagine
anything that he could say that would
shift Mansi Pelosi and Chuck Schumer and
appease that base but you know there
have been these negotiations going on to
some degree there within the house
why won't McConnell take what the house
is done and put it to a vote because
that would hurt the president the
president understands that his base once
that border wall and that's the kind of
been the only issue even McConnell's
been here before the president will be
here after the president why is he so
concerned with I know he's the president
but why is he so who's he protecting I
mean they're protecting the president or
insulating him politically from having
blowback from his own base and so yes
this is a co-equal branch in Congress
they could go and fund the government
separately that's certainly with
Democrats and even some Republicans have
been calling for but that will require
Mitch McConnell that require Kevin
McCarthy in the House to push the
president politically in ways they don't
want to do because they know he has such
a stranglehold on that base lots of vote
would go down and her constituents would
know exactly way they stood exactly all
right I stood I stood Herndon thank you
so thank you